la ceremonia será celebrada por el
arzobispo de Milán con un momento de
homenaje militar al féretro a la entrada
y a la salida de la catedral de la
ciudad seis carabineros uniformados
rodearán el ataúd de Silvio berluscommy
estarán presentes las grandes figuras
del mundo político italiano el
presidente italiano Sergio matarella la
jefa del gobierno italiano Georgia melón
Y al igual que los ex primeros ministros
Mateo renzi y Mario draghi 32 miembros
del actual gobierno volaron a Milán a
bordo de un vuelo Estatal institucional
organizado por el estado italiano
también se esperan personalidades
extranjeras cercanas a la familia
berlusconi y para todos aquellos que no
lograrán entrar dentro de la Catedral
han sido instalados pantallas gigantes
en la plaza a la cual podrán entrar unas
Diez mil personas para rendir un último
homenaje a Silvio verduzca y Natalia
este funeral también genera polémicas no
Sí así es para una parte de la opinión
pública italiana juzga excesiva toda
esta celebración es la primera vez que
se decreta una jornada de luto nacional
por la muerte de un antiguo jefe de
gobierno los votos en el parlamento
italiano han sido suspendidos hasta la
semana próxima en los edificios
institucionales de todo el país las
banderas están a media hasta y algunos
italianos consideran que todo esto es
demasiado para rendir homenaje a un
personaje que sin duda marcó la historia
del país por su extraordinaria
trayectoria por su instinto político
pero también por sus excesos sus
escándalos sexuales los problemas
judiciales con acusaciones gravísimas
por corrupción soborno y una condena
definitiva por evasión de impuestos
Entonces por supuesto Hoy es el día del
Duelo por la muerte de Silvio berlusconi
pero también hay italianos que
consideran inapropiada la manera en la
cual fue organizada este funeral